[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
y para eso nos acompaña daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida al estudio cuatro
grandes empresas demuestran que ya hay
signos de recesión mundial de qué se
trata así asmar y aclara muy buenas
noches pues varias multinacionales están
recortando gastos o empleos mientras que
otras están archivando proyectos a
medida que la inflación aumenta y la
confianza en la economía mundial se va
desvaneciendo para la muestra cuatro
ejemplos el primero de ellos el
minorista estadounidense de artículos
para el hogar bed bath and beyond dijo
que sus ventas en el primer trimestre
cayeron un 25 por ciento en consecuencia
lo que va a hacer es reducir sus gastos
de capital en igual proporción y no va a
remodelar ni a construir nuevas tiendas
el segundo caso el fabricante surcoreano
de baterías el 'día energy que es un
importante proveedor para las compañías
automotrices lo que está pensando lo que
está haciendo es pensarlo dos veces
antes de invertir
1.300 millones de dólares en una fábrica
en arizona la marca de autos eléctricos
tesla es el tercer ejemplo
una oficina en california y despidió a
200 empleados ya su dueño el
multimillonario y lo más que había
anticipado que necesitaba reducir en un
10% su plantilla de diez cien mil
empleados y la farmacéutica suiza
novartis anunció un programa de
reestructuración que incluye la
eliminación de ocho mil puestos de
trabajo o del 74 por ciento de su fuerza
laboral global apenas cuatro ejemplos de
muchísimos que podríamos dar y cambiamos
de noticia porque en eeuu está
incrementándose la venta de
anticonceptivos de emergencia porque sí
y lo hace porque el fallo de la corte
suprema que revocó el histórico road
versus white de 1973 que reconocía
recordemos el derecho constitucional de
las mujeres al aborto provocó un alza
temporal en la demanda de píldoras de
emergencia de venta libre también son
conocidas como plan b y se toman a pocos
días de la relación sexual las empresas
ya comenzaron a tomar medidas por
ejemplo el gigante del comercio
electrónico amazon estableció un límite
temporal de compra de tres unidades por
semana y por persona
cadena de farmacias y 10 ya había
aplicado una medida similar aunque dijo
que estaba a punto de suspender la
huelga si es el único que afirmó
seguirla vendiendo con toda regularidad
también hay que recordar mari aclara que
el departamento de salud y servicios
sociales de eeuu en desacuerdo con esta
medida de la corte se comprometió a
tomar medidas para aumentar el acceso a
los medicamentos abortivos ya que
recuerda que esto es un derecho de las
mujeres conseguirlos y de manera
gratuita y nos vamos a portugal donde se
reunieron los presidentes de los
principales bancos centrales del mundo
bueno los máximos dirigentes de la
reserva federal de eeuu el banco central
europeo y también el banco de inglaterra
estuvieron en un foro en la ciudad de
cintra y se mostraron decididos a
controlar la inflación
inclusive si eso costará sacrificar el
crecimiento escuchemos
estamos muy comprometidos con el uso de
nuestros instrumentos para conseguir que
la inflación baje y la manera de hacerlo
es frenar el crecimiento y como he
mencionado volver a equilibrar la oferta
y la demanda es lo que estamos tratando
de lograr existe el riesgo de que
vayamos demasiado lejos ciertamente hay
un riesgo pero yo no estaría de acuerdo
entonces el mayor riesgo para la
economía creo que el mayor error a
cometer sería no restaurar la
estabilidad de precios ya propósito de
los bancos en brasil renunció el
presidente de un banco estatal de quién
se trata y por qué renunció los maría
claras se trata de pedro guimaraes él
era el director de la entidad crediticia
estatal caixa económica federal y muy
aliado del presidente ya ir bolsonaro
está envuelto en un escándalo de
supuesto acoso sexual estas acusaciones
surgieron el martes por la noche cuando
el sitio web de noticias metro boles
informó del inicio de una investigación
oficial luego de que un grupo de
empleados de la entidad se quejará de
supuestos episodios de acoso sexual
guimaraes quienes será reemplazado por
una función del ministerio de economía
aseguró en su cuenta de instagram que
las acusaciones no son verdaderas ni
reflejan su postura profesional ni
personal y cuáles son los indicadores
del día wall street en cerró mixto y
después de que se confirmara una
contracción del 1,6 por ciento en la
economía estadounidense en el primer
trimestre en europa los mercados
terminaron en rojo siguen muy de cerca
desde luego las declaraciones no tan
optimistas esta vez de los banqueros
centrales en portugal y en américa
latina la bolsa mexicana cayó después de
conocerse que aeroméxico va a dejar de
cotizar sus acciones en este mercado y
la cifra del día 27 3% mar y clara esa
es la tasa de informalidad en chile que
ha venido creciendo a pesar de que la
tasa general de desempleo si ha caído
ahora se ubica en un 78 por ciento hace
un año era del 10% gracias daniela y
nosotros seguimos aquí